Hope you're having an amazing day
It's Mark wiens in Tokyo Japan
And I think the best reason to travel is for food and to experience the local culture
And local food in a typical day and so today
I'm going to take you on a japanese food tour of tokyo where we're going to eat my typical breakfast lunch and dinner
Meal set for would eat on just a normal day
Living in Japan and living in tokyo that's about 8 a.m.. Time for breakfast
In the first restaurant for breakfast. Yeah, this is a typical Japanese diner, and you come in here
You can get a variety of different dishes
And I think this place is actually open 24 hours
grab a tray and then you can
pick and choose whatever dishes to watch
One of the reasons I love coming to a diner so much is because they have such a different
selection of different Japanese Foods pre cooked Foods you had like a
whole Countertop full of different deep-fried Foods
But I kept it pretty traditional this would be a very common breakfast in Japan some grilled fish
I just couldn't resist ordering two types of grilled fish with a bowl of rice a couple sides of pickles and then miso soup what?
You do actually some of the food is it kind of sits and gets cold so they actually have some microwave the front
I'm going to go microwave my fish real fast
I'm going to adapt these fish in microwave real fast
30 seconds should do it. Oh yeah that brings out that to fish aroma
I'm going to start with the saba Mackerel one. This is a this is a very common type of fish
It's grilled or you can just see the buttery juices coming out of it. I'm a huge fan and
It's commonly served with Daikon, and this is like a puree Daikon radish. Oh
Yeah, that's all that's oily juicy fishy goodness
Oh, yeah
It's wonderful, and then you gotta Gotta Follow with rice of course
It's good. You know just
It's just good
fish
it's not too salty it pairs well with the daikon because the Daikon is sort of a
Refreshing refreshing taste to it. Oh
Yeah, that's like. It's actually kind of sweet and
a little bit salty um that kind of kind of works as a garnish for the whole meal miso soup, and they're
All kind of hanging weaker. I also got some eggplant is because well, just because I love eggplant oh
Mm-Hmm mmM
Has a nice and ginger flavor to it and that just as usual the reason
I love eggplant so much is because it just melts in your mouth. Okay next fish
And again, this is a grilled fish. It's a quite a long long little fish
That fish is a little bit drier than the saba Microbes
Still very good it has that kind of almost tuna dry texture to it
Either way either fish you you take it's a good choice
They do have some seasonings in the center of the table as well in the center console you have some soy sauce and pepper
and going in for the chili flakes
Probably my favorite thing on this plate is the classic the Saba the grilled Saba Mackerel
It's so I love the texture of it. I love the oiliness of it
with that with some daikon
and
Onto My my rice with chili
What a combination, you just love the butteriness of that natural law mmM. It's a it makes a wonderful breakfast
Breakfast was excellent. I feel ready to start the day and this is just a very typical Japanese food diner
You can get a selection of different food this particular. Dye
no, I'm fucking sure it's open 24 hours a day so you can come here at all times of the day and eat a
Simple, but filling meal you see people from all walks of life in there. That was the fantastic way to start the day
That breakfast held me over nicely until lunch and for lunch today. We're in Ginza
Which is one of the central business districts of tokyo and we're going to a restaurant which looks like it's a traditional place
It's an old restaurant a real classic, and I can't wait for lunch now. We've down this small little alley
This is the sign for the place right here
It went Sashimi attention
Used to call me son shoe. Yep. They're really very shortly
It's pretty packed at lunch, but we got the last two seats and we got here at 11:30 third
I think they just opened and they are already packing all they specialize in
Especially it's mostly seafood and fish and then they have a chicken puck here. Oh
How she means hanging in wow I got the low
Okay, the class of this restaurant is absolutely amazing and we ordered some of their lunch specials here
I didn't know we just we just talked with a friendly again tea here and she kind of just
ordered for us, and we got some of their specialties, they're
Edible, I think this is my new favorite place in tokyo and even I'm not only of those pages right now
I'm so excited. I can I don't even know what I'm talking about okay?
We got started eating here something that they're famous for is their chicken soup even though most of the food here is
people if you chunk the chicken
Okay, I'm going right in for that
our pot
Overall that is incredible that tastes like roasted chicken soup. It's salty
It's so pure and that chicken literally melt in your mouth
Oh, that's like the cleanest chicken to buy I've tasted in a very long time
This is a beautiful another beautiful plate of fresh sashimi those
Justice pointed and then there's some fresh muscat be over here on the side. I'm going to take some of that Wasabi
It onto that
Which is the thickness of that just tuna?
Man a little dip in it's like
That's the texture of a slab of butter, but so much better tasting there's zero strain and in that whatsoever
It's so thick and so extreme you
It's almost like crab and things are there and they also have a sauce here that you'll add to this
well
and for the final dish of lunch that I think this is fish as well look at that shit so meeting and
Seemed it looks like it's team
oh
That this is is the texture of butter again it just melts in your mouth. You can taste all those fish oils
It's so like light and fluffy that is
Impressively fresh and clean and just the texture is insane
The background is silk
That's one of the most tender pieces of chicken I've ever had without it being mushy
Just look at the size of this piece of tuna
That is a huge thick slice
Hey, we got those
We're just coming out of the restaurant. Oh, that's one of the the best meals. I've had in tokyo hands down that was
Impressive that is the type of like home-cooked japanese food meal that like you would dream about
The Sashimi was unbelievably fresh straight from ceg Market. I'm sure this morning
The fried shrimp were were like some of the medias like almost crab tasting shrimp that I've had
The chicken soup oh yeah that you can see if not even a seafood dish
But I don't even I don't even it's almost unexplainable
How pure and how clean and how like perfectly salt chili?
Addictive that was and the chicken that was literally like chicken that melted in your mouth
It's it was unbelievably soft and tender without being mushy whatsoever
I want to quickly say thank you to you
Go for recommending this spot saying that this is the traditional place that I needed to try that was just awesome
For dinner we headed over to shibuya a busy business and shopping area of tokyo to eat at a popular after work Izakaya serving
Yakitori right now crossing over shibuya crossing this is one of the world's busiest Pedestrian
crossings
And I'm on my way to go eat at a yakitori restaurant. Which is a Japanese grilled
chicken restaurant
We just made it into this yakitori restaurant
So cool, and I was lucky they if they actually have one they have two tables back here, but most of the seating is armed
Let some time with my family. I'm glad they had an open table
So we're sitting at the table although the bar counter seating would be the ultimate experience here, but you can just hang all here
We're not drilling chicken in here
They have a oh Arigatou~. Thank you. - yes, please - people - ah
- I thought they have a couple of many courses which are the omakase which that chefs inside and just give you a course
And let four course a that is the main one it includes a bunch of things well
I'm lime times like that
Okay, the surprise the first course on omekata menu is chicken Sashimi
So normally just about anywhere
You are in the world. You want to make sure that your chicken is cooked fully cooked cooked all the way through
But Japan is the one place for where they take such care
of their chickens and especially at a special chicken only chicken restaurant like this where they source their their chickens from
From reliable sources and that's a certain breed
organic chickens that they know where they're getting their chickens from
You can eat chicken Sashimi, and I've had it one other time before
This is beautiful presentation served with a dabble Wasabi on the side she said to put in some soy sauce the Bowl
We did with lime and just enjoy
Wow
oh
It's so tender
Well, I was expecting it to be a little more chewy. It doesn't have any kind of an off taste or anything like that
they are moving along with the courses this one is the "Tsukune" which I think is the
type of meatball the Decision like most like sausage Form oh
Yeah
Like taste the "Yuzu(柚子)" under which is a Japanese citrus
That's so juicy as well
こちらが皮ですね～
Educators when is about in Arcola to know from now on?
Baby welcome no more tears, okay in water
We had nothing to the course and keep moving along. I got I gotta eat
Meatball is fantastic It's like a sausage shaped me ball
You do not need
Any sauce or anything on that and moving along to my next birth this one is chicken Gizzard
And you can see it's a little bit bloody you can actually see like some little little
like Bubbles of grilled
Grilled bubbles on there, and then maybe some stone that's on there
I'm a big fan of kids or kids one of my favorite organs that has a nice crispness to it
It really even has a minerally taste of it
That's just like like like crunchy chicken these ones look pretty pretty fatty and pretty crunchy
I'm not sure if one of them is chicken skin, and then this one looks like that the back tail of the chicken
looks like A
Productive mixture of fatty chicken skin, but it looks you can see those like crunchy bubbles of them. I'm pretty backward
I think that chicken tails
Yeah, that is like like juicy fatty, but crunchy at the same time where it's been grilled
It's oily definitely, but it's packed with liver you can taste the pureness of the chicken in that bite
next when we were and this looks
Might be the chicken skin skewer just skin just like crunched up onto a skewer
It's glistening
Wow
It is rich
its crunchy its gooey its
Total bit salty you got that crispy layer from where it's been ripping sizzle over the charcoal that
Is it's very greasy, but it's very tasty and this appears to be
Maybe chicken thighs mixed with their flesh room on here, and there's the week isn't just a beautiful media Midi skewer
join us
That's just as good as it looks are just
Dark meat chicken, I got a shiitake mushroom in that bite
Smokey it's salty and I love how they they use such such little seasoning
I suddenly. It's really about the technique of how he grows
And about the quality of the ingredients including that the chicken that they're using
That's what really makes the up you tori special in Japan. I was waiting for the next course
I was wondering when this was going to come because chicken liver well, I just love Chicken liver
This is gorgeous. You can see even how they arranged it on the on the skewers. It's like from small to bigger
That'd be a different part
I don't even know how they've just say they know all the anatomy of the chicken and you can see how it Inaudi
It's actually better if they like
Wow
Okay, that's the bite of the meal right there
Paul it has like this kind of almost like leathery
skin around the outside from being grilled, but then on the inside of just literally like
Bursts, I get a picture in my mind of like one of those is it called the Lava cake
Where you break it open and like juice like like like liquid chocolate just flows out of it
That is what this liver like sort of does in your mouth except of course instead of chocolate. It's liquid deliver
This was a complete surprise to me. I won't ever say no to eel and then she sprinkled on
pepper cement a spiker there
It just falls apart it has a wonder wonderful Smoky flavor to it as well
Okay, next thank you, er. And it appears to be chicken breast nice big chunk sizes
Forgot to mention, but you can see there's some Wasabi on there as well, and that's not just your average
dry piece of chicken breast
It's so juicy well it just gushes with juice. Oh
And that's only how cooked chicken breast it so as you can see how Rod is on the inside
These are quail legs. I think they're quail eggs, and what looks like
They appear to be Bucco nuts
right off the Grill
That's just like
Explain they're just straight up quail eggs and gingko nuts, and this is our final course. Thank you kaki mushrooms
They're big, and they're really big in the Media
And how much of potato or juicy sauce and like silky?
silky rubbery at the same time
We just finished with the yakitori Corson. Come outside. I didn't even know it's raining out here
Oh, I was in like a little bit of a chicken
Paradise heaven inside there without even knowing what was going on on the on the outside
What just amazes me so much about Japanese food in General? Is that how they take just simple?
Single ingredients like chicken and just do amazing things with it, but you know like I'm a spice guy. I love spices
I love like overpowering
spices which Japanese food is not, but I love it because it's so
It's so precise. It's so quality and they just focus on the single paste of those ingredients
but they know how to enhance it so well and
Yakitori is a perfect example of that
Japanese cooking expertise
that was amazing and that brings us to the end of this japanese food tour video including breakfast lunch and dinner in tokyo and
While I was there that night it started raining
And then we had to get home, so I actually completely forgot about making an ending to this video. So I'm back at home now
But that was a fantastic day the food was amazing and it was
Lots of food I'm going to leave all of the information in the description box below all of the restaurants at yet
And all the details so you can check that out there, and I want to say a big thank you for watching this video
Please remember to give it a thumbs up if you enjoyed it
I'd love to hear from you in the comment section below and if you're not already subscribed
Click subscribe now for lots more food and travel videos, and I'll see you on the next video. Thanks again for watching